so steht er vor der weltpresse vor zwei
stunden takt über schirm genfer see
erfahren dass er den höchsten preis der
wissenschaft erhält den nobelpreis in
chemie
dieser vierte oktober 2017 wird sein
leben verändern kann ich noch eine frage
stellen für deutschschweizer fernsehen
aber die branche hat wenig geduld mit
mir hören sie ich gehe
nein einen moment hat sie forschung
schon immer interessiert seit frühester
kindheit als fünfjährigen theater stimmt
die forschung war mir immer wichtig sie
gibt mir die kraft zu lieben
dank der forschung habe ich keine angst
mehr
ich hatte als kind angst vor den 8
sobald ich begann die zusammenhänge zu
verstehen habe ich besser gelebt
der pensionierte 76 jährige forscher
werden diesem moment hinauskatapultiert
aus dem labor in die welt der medien
was passiert als nächstes achtung sie
stoßen sich mit ihrer kamera in dieser
geschichte geht es um einen schweizer
forscher der die wissenschaft verändert
hat und darum wie der höchste preis der
wissenschaft ihn verändern wird
[Musik]
das scheinwerferlicht wirtschaft die
moschee lange begleiten das sehe ich im
laufe der nächsten monate nicht ohne
folgen wie sich zeigen wird
[Musik]
dort hinten geht die sonne auf
auf den bergen schnee der wind wirbelt
alles auf herrlich einen monat später am
genfer see die bosch erhält 500 e-mails
jeden tag mittlerweile organisiert eine
assistentin seine zahllosen
interview-termine trotz stress ist er
der nobelpreisträger offen und
zugänglich
ich habe meinen wilhelm vergessen
entschuldigen sie ich muss den helm
holen er zeigt uns jenes labor in dem
alles begann
hier geschehen ja sachen das ist solch
ein apparat der uns den nobelpreis
eingebracht hat diesen da die hand
zittert seine angst vor einer krankheit
ließ sich der wissenschaft aber vom
doktor nehmen
glücklicherweise hat mir der doktor
gesagt er sei kein parkinson
welch ein glück 1980 gelang es seinem
forschungsteam weltweit erstmals in
gefrorenem wasser biomoleküle sichtbar
zu machen so wurden plötzlich zahlreiche
krankheiten unter einem mikroskop
erkennbar
ihm war sofort bewusst diese entdeckung
wird die wissenschaft revolutionieren
mein kollege erinnert sich noch gut wie
ich damals reagiert habe forscher aus
der ganzen welt arbeiten seither mit
über schätzgrundlage der kryo
elektronenmikroskopie dank dieser
methode werden sämtliche biologischen
partikel proteine virus erstmals
sichtbar die im gefrorenen wasser
schwimmen dann sieht man plötzlich alles
wie ein protein verdreht ist warum wie
entwickelt sich eine krankheit dann
leben wir die branche den flüssigen
stickstoff vor die füße
jahrelang hat er nach seiner entdeckung
vom nobelpreis geträumt nun aber zwei
wochen vor der preisübergabe zehrt das
aufsehen um seine person am waadtländer
schauen sie die hummel
mehr aufhören die welt der wissenschaft
wird mich überall an konferenzen
einladen ein interview folgt auf das
andere
das hört erst auf wenn ich komplett
verrückt bin oder tod
diese sache mit dem nobelpreis wird nie
mehr auf was sagt ihre frau dazu sie ist
beunruhigt ja sie ist beunruhigt
[Musik]
lichterlöschen im labor
während sein name um die welt geht
anfang dezember reist das ehepaar über
scheren die verleihung des nobelpreises
nach stockholm eingeladen in der
business class seine frau christin sagt
mir sie sei vor allem an den nobelpreis
erst im pensionsalter erhalten jetzt sei
er besser geerdet
[Musik]
es ist nicht selbstverständlich für mich
hier dabei zu sein ich habe gezögert
aber jetzt bin ich zufrieden an der
seite meines sympathischen mannes zu
sein
ich realisiere es noch nicht seit zwei
monaten nehme ich nur noch tag für tag
und entdecke jeden tag mit großem
erstaunen
[Musik]
per limousine geht es weiter zur
schneiderin das nobelpreis komitee
organisiert den tagesablauf der
preisträger minuziös
[Musik]
das sitzt perfekt sie sieht nahe beim
könig dafür brauchen sie glänzende
schuhe
[Musik]
ich finde mich sehr schön eindrücklich
aber du musst verstehen ich miete dies
nur und werde solche kleider nicht nach
hause nehmen um dann geben sonntag damit
meine familie zu beeindrucken
ich denke mir es gibt wohl ein leben vor
und eines nach dem nobelpreis die
weltpresse erwartet ihn und seine zwei
preisträger kollegen
dem star to place und thea nobelpreis in
chemie
die welt ist groß sehr groß
mein kopf ist ziemlich klein
es ist unmöglich die welt in meinen kopf
zu bringen
ein erstaunlicher weg vom kind aus angst
vor der nacht hatte zum nobelpreis
gewinner der könig carl gustaf die hand
schüttelt
[Musik]
[Applaus]
mitte februar die uni lausanne er ihr
neues aushängeschild 2000 geladene gäste
erweisen dem nobelpreisträger die ihre
passen sie auch nicht dass sie stürzen
ein wenig glanz des nun weltweit
bekannten wissenschafters fällt auch auf
die politik und gesellschaft hier
[Applaus]
herr professor lieber sagt die branche
wir sind geblendet von ihre forschung
und ihren nobelpreis von ihrem naturell
ihre authentizität profitieren wir alle
ein bisschen die goldene nobelpreis
medaille übergibt die moschee
anschließend der uni rektoren das ist
eine gute kopie für unsere universität
sie ist wunderschön die namen der
universität danke die busse für die spd
im gemeinderat morsch nutzt die bühne
für seine politische botschaft
wissenschaft im dienste aller stellen
sie sich vor dass tank unsere crew
mikroskopie im nächsten jahr ein
alzheimer medikament entwickelt wird
wissen sie was dann passiert sie werden
sich bis aufs blut bekämpfen um die
patentrechte um dann das medikament für
100000 franken zu verkaufen obwohl es
auch für 100 franken ging
[Applaus]
[Musik]
doch die branche lässt john lennon
sprechen frau christin und tochter lucy
im publikum
[Musik]
was löst das in ihm aus seit monaten
gefeiert zu werden wir auf der bühne gab
es wissenschafter die genauso gut sind
wie ich plötzlich hebt man dann einen
hervor und stellt sie in den mittelpunkt
das ist problematisch
diese wissenschaftspreise picken ein
individuum heraus und geben ihm eine
große aura das hat etwas giftiges an
sich ist entführt ihn zunächst in
interviews
[Musik]
zusammen mit seiner frau kristin hat er
vor drei jahren bei sich zu hause eine
somalische asylbewerberin aufgenommen
ein engagement das beiden wichtig ist
dass die wissenschaftlichen ehren so
viel platz einnehmen ist die putzfrau
nicht mehr ganz geheuer verwirklichen
was bis jetzt vielleicht gar nicht so
gut können und was ist stress und das
macht bereits anstatt das stimmt ja
bush anfang april
ich treffe die branche zum vierten mal
ob ich für deutschschweizer fernsehen
arbeitet fragte mich unvermittelt und
wechselt überraschend auf hochdeutsch
ich staune was seine frau mit der
rastlosigkeit des pensionierten
intellektuellen meint erfahre ich hier
in jeder freien minute hat jack die
branche nebst seinen nobelpreis
verpflichtungen an seinem ersten buch
geschrieben
mitte mai ist ein buch erschienen auf
über 200 seiten schreibt ueberschär über
seine forschung kritisiert dass die
wissenschaft zu sehr im dienste der
konzerne stehe am meisten scheinenden
wissenschaftler aber philosophische
fragen zu beschäftigen fragen über das
leben unser dasein und die zukunft
plötzlich habe ich das wort und so
möchte ich das benützen
weil ich möchte so was sind ihre ideen
so dass zum beispiel das leben hat
keinen sinn
das leben hat noch den sinn dass man das
ich selber hineinbringt das ist eine
achte geschichte was sind ihre welt im
leben ihre grundwerte und ja ich frage
dich ich stelle die frage nicht jetzt
dann aber die meisten fällen wissen die
leute haben die leute keine antwort
lustige frage und das ist ein skandal
natürlich man sollte ganz genau wissen
war was die werke sind im büro des
forschers sich vieles aber nichts weist
auf die nobelpreis hin
ja aber ich habe da mit einem original
gemälde ja immerhin das nicht ja
immerhin das aber wissen sie ich werde
die nobelpreis nicht vergessen und wenn
ich ihn vergesse dann brauche ich auch
die medaille nicht mehr
aber diese habe ich meine nobelpreis
medaille aus schokolade
das reicht sie ist bereits ein bisschen
geschmolzen
ich frage mich welche spuren der
nobelpreis bei ihm hinterlassen hat
plötzlich gibt es diese lawine wenn man
nicht mehr zeit hat ruhig in die wald zu
spazieren oder so um auf sich wieder zu
kommen dann ja dann wird man
werden dann verliert man sich verändern
sie sich immer noch wirklicher mit dem
preis kann ich ihnen sagen was meine
kinder sagen ja gemacht du du wirst du
gehst du wirst egoistisch wie das
natürlich alle leute schauen die hand
ja ja ja ich bin sehr groß die
auszeichnung hat sein leben auf den kopf
gestellt doch die moschee bleibt sich
treu
minuziös sammelt er wissen festgehalten
in notizbücher du siehst dich mache die
ganze zeit meine notizen
das ist das erste heftige 2007 also ich
pensioniert wurde
darin sind alle diskussionen
festgehalten
deshalb nein nur die interessanten
diskussionen
ich fahre mit die moschee nach lausanne
dort gibt er seit einigen jahren
unbegleiteten jungen asyl bewerbe
nachhilfeunterricht seine schulzeit
verlief nicht immer problemlos
und dann ging es bergab ergab
jetzt habe ich ein nobelpreis gibt es
noch fragen
ballack
seinen weg machte er auch dank lehrern
die an den jungen jack geglaubt haben
trotz seiner dies lag sie heute wieder
jenen helfen die weniger glück im leben
gehabt haben als er bist du bereits
umgezogen working gut bist du zufrieden
es ist gut gegangen
lebst du ganz alleine ja nemat flüchtet
er alleine vor dem krieg mit 15 kam er
von afghanistan in die schweiz zu fuß im
winter über die berge wie viele quadrate
sind im rechteck 120 120 ist er streng
als mathematiklehrer er ist wie ein
großvater für mich ja aber nicht sehr
aktiv
man muss sich nichts vormachen abwesend
zu oft manchmal machen wir etwas
zusammen
danke wirst du gekommen das war sehr gut
du bist ein geschenk für mich
die angst vor nach der die moschee als
kind mit wissen vertrieben jetzt mit 76
ist er plötzlich die angst sein wissen
zu verlieren
von die medizin und für meine familie
erwarte und dass das ist so dass ich
mich nicht finde
um an diese langen weg zum sterben von
eine alzheimer patient zu vermeiden
zurück zum labor der universität
lausanne
sehen sie das ist lustig an vielen
universitäten haben sie für
nobelpreisträger einen großen parkplatz
eingerichtet
für große autos das ist sympathisch für
mein wille aber jetzt bin ich nicht mehr
mit dem velo gekommen
ich glaube ich muss mir extra ein
fahrrad kaufen um den parkplatz hier zu
belegen
heute scheint mir hat die bosch seinen
nobelpreis angenommen er erinnert sich
an den entscheidenden moment am vierten
oktober und 10 uhr 40 hat mein handy
hier in meinem büro geklingelt ich teile
das büro mit doktoranden drei andere
waren da im büro das war zwar drängen es
kommt die marie maria dann haben sie es
genommen nein er ist nicht da naja wer
ist wichtig denn wenn sie nach 20
minuten gebraucht um mich zu finden zu
hause war das war die geschichte
[Musik]